now i gotta say he's working his ass off
here
now i've got to say i'm working my ass
off here this is
this is sleepy joe the guy goes the guy
goes to his basement
he's he's got another lid
all right as the election approaches
we're watching two competing magic acts
while trump is in three places at once
the dems give us an invisible joe
he's laying low saying very little and
the little he says
he gets wrong it's historic biden's the
first candidate to say
the less of me the better maybe he's
banking on the fact that it's not about
him at all it's about the other guy
what's his name was it george four more
years of george uh
georgia he uh is going to find ourselves
in a position where
if uh trump gets elected uh we're gonna
be uh we're gonna be in a different
world
so is it four more years of george bush
or four more years of joe's host
george lopez you decide i tell you one
george is a really really funny dude
the other is lopez but if you were
looking for a vanishing act
joe's your guy there's nothing up his
sleeve or anywhere else
and unlike trump he won't tell you what
he thinks his evasiveness on fracking
reveals
he's waiting for instructions as for
packing the court he boldly states
let's have a commission which is like
boldly stating i want a nap
but driving through pennsylvania this
weekend i saw
no signs of biden but i did see biden
signs
while joe hides his voters don't because
voting for him
it's safe not so with trump he's
out there but with the exception of
rallies his voters aren't
it's because for the first time sadly
saying who you'll vote for
could get you hurt but where there
weren't any signs
there were indeed american flags maybe
those are signs
too a wink not a shout as the left vows
punishment for those they deem evil
and cities erupt with riots sorry
peaceful protests
it sent a message to half of america the
deplorables
take a lid and they have but unlike joe
they'll wake up on election day
because they know if they don't the
magic trick will be a disappearing
america
all right juan we're back in the boxes
i'm in a van in the middle of nowhere
you're in a van in the middle of dc
i'm shouting uh what do you make of the
contrast
what do you make of the contrast between
the enthusiasm and action
of of trump and the kind of like
absent lethargy of joe biden i think i
set it up in an
unbiased fashion is that right
fair fair always fair always so fair
like like that thing with george lopez
that was so
fair to joe biden you know what i think
when i look at these rallies greg i i
think to myself you know this election
has become a referendum on trump he
didn't want that uh he wanted to be able
to
make it a choice election but it's not
it's really a referendum on trump at
this point
and the rallies you know i think to
myself the rallies can be fun
i mean it's entertaining to go watch but
the rallies aren't convincing anyone
that covets going away
the rallies aren't convincing anyone
that somehow trump has come up with a
good health care plan for america that
that's just not
that's just not true or real and in fact
the more he talks
sometimes he gets himself in big trouble
uh the other day he said
american doctors are in fact reporting
more cases of coronavirus because
they get paid more if they do or another
time he said gretchen whitmer the
governor of michigan
again he attacked her even though she
has been the subject
of an attempted kidnapping plot he
attacked the governor of pennsylvania
tom wolf
said it was threatening him i guess
threatening not physically but
threatening federal funds for the
citizens of pennsylvania
so i think to myself in addition to
these rallies being potentially super
spreader events
i think half of them have been linked to
spikes in coronavirus
i think he hurts himself often in these
rallies
and that's not good for him
okay so uh jesse i'm gonna quote not
quote but bring up scott adams
who uh brings up the concept of
reciprocity
that when you have a candidate giving a
hundred and ten percent
uh up to the finish line you feel
compelled to reciprocate and vote do you
buy that
i do i people are given their blood
sweat and tears to
wait and drive to a rally with 10
20 000 other trump supporters around
them it's funny to listen to
juan try to spin massive crowds for a
presidential re-election campaign as
somehow a bad
thing never in history have we seen
people try to say the more people to
show up to listen to you
the worse you're going to do on election
day it didn't work in 2016 and it's not
going to work in 2020 right now
donald trump doesn't need to change a
thing donald trump's in the driver's
seat it's joe
biden who's actually struggling right
now and you can tell
why the media is trying to change the
way they frame
his light schedule they used to say his
light schedule was smart strategy
look at the polls and they're not saying
that anymore they're saying his light
strategy
is a risky gamble and it is a risky
gamble
and here's why he's not going out
there's a host of reasons one
he cannot contract covid19 because that
destroys
the central premise of his candidacy
which is i'm safe
i'm going to lead by example i'm going
to wash my hands social distance and
wear a mask and protect myself
so if he gets it it's lights out it's
also he's gonna show up and no one's
gonna show up to listen to him
and it's humiliating and the more he
shows up the more stupid things come out
of his mouth
so it is smart i guess for him to lay
low but it's not going to work right now
trump is storming these battlegrounds
he's now ahead in the real clear
politics average in florida
in ohio last poll came out in
pennsylvania trump's up two
last poll that came out in north
carolina it's tight last poll in arizona
trump's up one
the same thing is happening is happening
in 2016
and the media did it to themself with
their fake polls and the fake news
it's setting it up for a huge comeback
and right now joe's on the defensive on
fracking on oil on corruption
on taxes and the trump campaign is
dropping a massive ad
by hitting joe for siding with the
rioters
against the police
you know degan what i don't understand
is i listen to the pro-biden media
and they constantly say how likable he
is which is probably true
but why not have mr likable out there
more if he's so likable
why are you hiding the most popular guy
in the world
well i like people too if i don't have
to see them or hear them or associate
with them at all
so i understand that one of the reasons
that
one of the reasons that joe biden is
laying low is because it's not the super
flub
is it george bush maybe it was george
washington or maybe it was george
jetson and his boy elroy that he was
talking about
it is the moment when a politician
screws up
but actually tells you what he's
planning to do
and the way he views this country and
joe biden
jesse mentioned it did that in the
debate when he said
essentially i'm going to get rid of the
oil industry because it's dirty
this goes to potentially destroying
millions of jobs in this country
destroying the prosperity that rural
communities have experienced because of
fracking
it is handing power to nations that hate
us they want to wipe us off the map
after we
finally reached the top position in oil
production
in the world and more than anything it's
raising prices on all americans it's a
tax when you raise people's energy
prices we use oil and natural gas
because it's plentiful and cheap and
he's promising a regressive tax
that hurts the lowest income americans
the most and that is his world where
american is america is poorer and
there's more power
in the hands of government and that is
hell on earth
all right last word to you dana what say
you other than how happy you are to be
back in a van or in your home
yes um the jasper's not allowed in the
van so
that's kind of a bummer but um i
understand why although
i don't know dave would probably let
jasper in the van so the word of the
week is energy
energy when it comes to the feeling out
on the campaign trail and president
trump is out there doing it and he's
also focusing on that issue as degan
just laid out
um there's one other thing i would
mention though is that the democrats
um and the left it's showing a lot of
energy when it comes to
donations there's so much money heading
into these races
republicans are being outspent in many
of the states and
you don't see republicans complaining
and demanding campaign finance reform
they're just out there trying to compete